I was studying at Great Ormond Street  Hospital for pediatric nursing degree I  was living with my boyfriend we'd been  together five years and one day he said  he was moving out I felt like someone  had ripped out half of my heart I just  was a mess I'd borrowed so much money I  was in so much debt  I just couldn't see a way out of it  you're under arrest  you're being charged with conspiring to  export cocaine there are seven kilos of  cocaine in the packages  they took my things out of my kit put  them in their cases I didn't see any  drugs  they didn't tell me where it was  they just gave me them and took my case  I've got two suitcases the stuff full of  a woman tapped me on the shoulder it's a  live mr. Robertson I just thought how  does she know my name it's your name  Nasser Robertson and is this your case  my heart was pounding in my chest I felt  sick to my stomach please come with me